there's no star wars movie coming out in
2022 but top gun maverick might just
fill the gap
top gun maverick hasn't had an easy
flight to the big screen the joseph
kaczynski directed sequel was originally
set for a july 2019 release although
that was first pushed back to june 24th
2020 so there was more time to work on
some of the action scenes obviously the
pandemic quickly threw many release
dates out the window and maverick
slipped three more times before
eventually settling on its may 2022 date
judging by the incredible reaction from
critics it's been well worth the wait
top gun maverick picks up with tom
cruise's pete maverick mitchell who has
refused to move up the chain of command
in the years since the original top gun
back in 1986 instead he spends most of
his time testing experimental aircraft
simply as a way of staying in the skies
when he disobeys direct orders as any
maverick is wanted to do the captain is
forced to return to the top gun school
to help train a batch of incredibly
talented pilots to carry out an
unprecedented mission overseas the team
has to fly into a mountainous region of
enemy territory avoid anti-aircraft
missiles and destroy a uranium facility
built into the mountain as if that isn't
enough the flyboy also has to reckon
with bradley rooster bradshaw the son of
his fallen wingman nick goose bradshaw
the action-packed finale is a
hair-raising sequence as kaczynski
cranks up the tension pushing maverick
and the team closer to danger although
the original top gun is a hollywood
classic in its own right the climactic
scene of the new sequel actually owes a
major debt to another legendary
franchise star wars once you notice the
comparison it's impossible to unsee
the ending of top gun maverick
absolutely borrows its action from the
ending of 1977's star wars a new hope
the whole mission that maverick trains
the pilots for is to infiltrate a
mountainous region of an unnamed hostile
nation so that they can destroy a
uranium enrichment plant that has been
built inside two mountains according to
intelligence the enemy has nearly
finished working on the uranium meaning
they'll soon have their hands on nuclear
weapons the mission itself requires the
pilots to fly very low through an
incredibly tight valley so that they
avoid detection by enemy radar which
would send anti-aircraft missiles
hurtling toward them once they make it
through up into the mountains they have
to shoot a missile into what is
essentially a large exhaust pipe
sticking out of the ground one that
leads down into the heart of the
facility itself now if that sounds
familiar that's because it's practically
beat for beat the same run luke
skywalker and friends have to make at
the end of a new hope remember the rebel
fighter pilots fly down the trench in
the death star staying low to avoid all
the tie fighters and laser turrets
before shooting two proton torpedoes
into the base's thermal exhaust port
which is connected to the main reactor
obviously this destroys the death star
completely and takes a weapon of mass
destruction out of the empire's hands
obviously top gun maverick is very much
its own beast compared to a new hope
mainly because it's about a man
reckoning with his own legacy as he also
trains his own replacements star wars is
much more about the battle between good
and evil while also being a completely
different type of action film but it is
funny that there are so many close
comparisons between the two the enemy
fighter pilots and maverick even wear
black tinted helmets like disposable tie
fighter pilots they'd probably get on
well with the empire but was director
joseph kaczynski intending to make a
star wars homage in the tom cruise
vehicle sort of when slash films spoke
to the director on the red carpet he
explained that star wars wasn't on his
mind while shooting maverick however he
noted that the sci-fi classic has always
been a part of top gun in a small way
paying tribute to top gun producer jerry
bruckheimer and the inspirations in the
air at the time
i think when jerry made
top gun i think star wars was definitely
an inspiration for them so it makes
sense that that dna would carry into
ours thankfully maverick and rooster
have a much better relationship than
darth vader and luke skywalker by the
end of the film maverick has essentially
filled that father figure role for his
fallen friend's son and they even repair
a plane together cute oh and maverick
doesn't repeatedly try to kill rooster
with a lightsaber so there's that too as
for the dangling question of why the
nefarious foreign enemy and top gun
maverick took its lair construction cues
from the fatally flawed death star we'll
likely never have a satisfactory answer
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you